has been removing the symbols of its
Soviet past since Independence in 1991
you can now cheaply buy a bust of Lenin
should you want one but collector
volodimir linvi says nobody does
I think it is so important it is history
and if you forget history then there's
nothing left
for many it is history that has
delivered War
and with it the process known as
de-communization has given way to
de-russification the government has
legislated against the publication of
books by Russian authors the teaching of
Russian in schools and Russian being
spoken in government departments and
some public settings it's especially
Stark in a city like kharkiv 50
kilometers from the Russian border
majority Russian speaking and we're the
longest Boulevard once called moskowsky
Avenue is now renamed after the heroes
of harkiv it is a complex idea as the
war goes on and before reconstruction in
Ukraine has really had a chance to get
underway this effort to erase the marks
of its giant neighbor whose language
most ukrainians can speak and understand
whose culture and history certainly
older ukrainians would have grown up
with so Ukraine was not created like in
1991 mabato we have centuries of our
independence but it is an effort that
some say cannot be compromised the
government is moving too slowly says
Oleg slavospitsky and his fellow
activists so they do what they can to
speed things along
I feel that the only correct recipe is
respect Nations can live without War
only if they respect each other if
Russia respects our choice of History
culture language and army there may be
in years to come in future Generations
we'll find a formula for coexistence
Maria avdiva remained in kharkiv
recording on social media the Relentless
daily bombardment of the city in the
early stages of the war
specifically saying that they in
make safe
place for the russian-speaking people
which was never the case but Russia used
it and they used this historical and
cultural background to legitimize their
Invasion and this is why people feel
urge to change that
few in Ukraine argue otherwise Jonah
Hall Al Jazeera kharkiv